[Music]
on this friday night police push back
you will be arrested if you do not leave
dozens are arrested as police and
protesters face off we're focused on
returning our city to the place that we
all know and love we'll bring you the
very latest from the police operation
happening now near parliament hill also
tonight evacuation order pro-russian
separatists tell civilians to flee
ukraine fueling fears of an imminent
russian invasion the united states and
our allies are prepared to defend every
inch of nato territory and the view from
neighboring poland where officials are
bracing for a rush of refugees plus race
to the finish canada's climbing metal
count as the winter games slide into
their final weekend
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semper will be
arrested if you do not leave those with
vehicles
we'll take a look at this extraordinary
show of force in the nation's capital
hundreds of officers from right across
the country spent the day methodically
pushing protesters out of the streets
that they've been blocking for 22 days
good evening and thank you for joining
us tensions are running high in ottawa
tonight police have arrested dozens of
protesters and towed more than 20 trucks
the operation remained largely peaceful
for most of the day but tonight we're
seeing more clashes between police and
the remaining protesters who are
refusing to back down and that police
operation appears far from over we will
run this operation 24 hours a day until
the residents and community have their
entire
city back
officers are inching closer to the
epicenter of the occupation just outside
of parliament that's where a large
contingent of protesters remain along
with our mike armstrong who has been
tracking the situation for us and joins
us live from parliament hill so mike
what's the latest
well jeff we've had vehicles leaving
even over the course of the last hour
this has been the very much the core the
middle of this protest
the vehicles that are leaving here are
leaving voluntarily the vehicle is about
500 meters to my right much less so
that's where the police operation
continues right now and where it kicked
off this morning at about eight o'clock
local time
police started with what was effectively
the eastern flank of the protest groups
of trucks set off from the main protest
site
[Music]
[Applause]
they moved foot by foot taking control
of block after block the world
is disgusting
as police moved there were skirmishes
and arrests in some cases people
appeared to want to be taken into
custody in other cases it was clear they
didn't want to go can you take my
sunglasses
i'm not
now as the police line took control of
an area with trucks they would speak to
the driver and ask them to leave
you got a chance to get out now we're
going to
where the person refused officers would
break the windows and pull the driver
out several vehicles were then towed
away
as that was happening on the eastern
flank there were truckers in the main
protest site who decided to pull out on
their own protest organizers meantime
continued to call on members of the
public to try to join the protest the
tactics are pretty obvious just get here
get into ottawa sit there until somebody
listens
now getting downtown isn't an easy thing
to do while there are officers facing
off with protesters in one area there
are police checkpoints and roadblocks
just about everywhere else access to the
downtown core has been cut off for
anyone who doesn't work or live in the
area getting around downtown and in
adjacent neighborhoods is a challenge a
much larger area of the city is now
being seriously affected i'm not here to
debate with you but also affected our
protesters if they're not in the
downtown core already they're not
getting in that's effectively cut off
fuel supplies and frustrated many
you're looking at checks once this is
done they're all going to be out of work
could you please step out of the vehicle
sir another protest leader was arrested
friday morning pat king who's been a
vocal presence since the beginning was
taken into custody he posted his arrest
online i'm being arrested by these
officers right now
this officer here they've cornered me
had me at the ready and
i'm being arrested
ottawa police have been keeping a
running tally uh put it posting it on
twitter the latest numbers they put out
70 arrests 21 vehicles towed we do know
that that is not a complete figure
because they posted something recently
saying someone threw a bicycle at one of
the police horses and that person was
arrested they're also saying protesters
have assaulted officers and attempted to
remove officers weapons they're saying
they're insisting trying to de-escalate
also they're saying this operation will
go on throughout the night jeff
mike armstrong in ottawa thanks mike
and that police strategy now being
deployed to remove demonstrators is
unlike anything seen in recent memory
from other large-scale protests it began
as a slow coordinated effort to push
protesters out but that situation now
appears to be shifting our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson spent much of
the day on the ground amid the protest
and she joins us now so mercedes how
would you describe the police tactics
that you saw out there today
well jeff earlier in the day they were
not dressed in tactical gear they were
at the front lines just in soft hats and
normal police clothing there were layers
of security back behind them including
the public order and mounted units that
we're now seeing come forward this
evening and finally the emergency
response team and tactical teams behind
that so a layered approach but
essentially they were trying to push
protesters back this came after
arresting as mike mentioned a number of
the leaders which was designed to
demoralize them the hope was that they
could convince people to leave if they
simply pushed them away and took away
the leadership there was a desire to try
to do this with as few arrests as
possible from what i'm hearing because
every arrest as you can imagine is a lot
of paperwork and also the desire was to
take back the area and then hold it so
that people couldn't get back into those
trucks we are seeing that evolve over
the evening as this is becoming much
more confrontational after a lot of the
people who have chosen to leave have
left and what you're getting is the
people who are truly entrenched at this
point but in terms of what the overall
police strategy looks like we talked to
vern white he's a senator now but he's
also the former chief of police here in
ottawa here's what he had to say
i think it's about moving down taking
space each each time you go down take
that space from them remove the people
who are refusing to leave hopefully
enticing a large number that you know
what i came here for protests i didn't
come here for jail or certainly didn't
come here for a criminal record and a
lot of those people helped them get out
of the city
and mercedes given the slow speed of the
operation so far how long is this
enforcement effort expected to take
that's a great question it was super
slow this morning and it seems to be
speeding up significantly tonight as the
police is using the mounted unit to try
to push people back but i spoke to jim
bremner he's the head of the canadian
tactical officers association about how
long he thinks this could take take a
listen to what he has to say
it's going to be inch by inch and it's
going to be based on
uh again each individual and how they
want to acquiesce
uh
i'm i'm going to say we're probably a
week away
to clearing this because it's going to
take
uh you know at least an hour hour and a
half to clear each vehicle
now at this hour jeff a number of
vehicles have cleared off of wellington
which police sources were telling me
were going to be the most difficult part
of the street to clear so so that may
take a little bit less time but
certainly this is a very fluid situation
and it's evolving very rapidly but the
police are hoping to do this with as
little violence as possible and i'm sure
some of the protesters are hoping for
that too
all right mercedes-stephenson in ottawa
thanks
and let's go now to sean o'shea who has
also been on the ground in ottawa for us
all day and he joins us now from near
the chateau laurier just east of
parliament hill so sean how would you
describe the mood of the remaining
protesters there
well jeff it's uh it's things have
changed and through the earlier part of
the day it was the hardcore people the
truckers that sort of thing but as the
day has progressed the afternoon has
gone on now we see hundreds of people
who have just come from the community
who are supporting or blowing horns who
have their flags and who are joining in
this and making things more difficult
for the police who are here for the
provincial police ontario provincial
police the quebec provincial police
we just watched an arrest a moment ago
uh for uh
violation of the public safety and so
it's uh it's people a lot of drinking
going on a lot of people who are here to
have their voices heard different voices
heard
which have nothing to do necessarily
with the original truckers protests so
what again began early today as a fairly
straightforward we're not going to leave
now we have all these additional people
who have come here today and you got to
remember that yesterday the police
people told people
not to come to the community they said
that people should not in fact come
because there would be problems and they
tried to cut off access here by virtue
guys checkpoints but that didn't work as
you can see
completely different scenario tonight as
it was yesterday jeff we'll send it back
to you yeah we'll leave it there shawn
o'shea in a very loud very fluid
situation in ottawa stay safe thanks
sean
a class action lawsuit against the
organizers of that ottawa occupation is
now expanding dozens of new defendants
have just been named in the litigation
which now includes donors who
contributed money to the campaign after
february the 4th that was the day
gofundme canceled the initial fundraiser
on its website citing concerns the money
could be used for unlawful activity the
lawsuit consists of thousands of
residents and hundreds of business
owners in downtown ottawa they're
seeking 306 million dollars in
compensation
and the canadian civil liberties
association says it plans to sue the
federal government over its decision to
invoke the emergencies act the group
alleges that act infringes on canadians
charter rights and that the thresholds
required to use it have not been met
the government's use of the emergencies
act was supposed to be debated by mps on
parliament hill today ahead of a vote
next week but the police operation in
ottawa has put that debate on hold the
house of commons did not sit today the
house speaker says the debate was
canceled due to security concerns citing
the police enforcement on parliament
hill mps are expected to resume those
talks next week
coming up preparing for war
the u.s president warns that vladimir
putin has just decided to launch an
invasion of ukraine just as thousands of
civilians are ordered to evacuate
welcome back there is breaking news
tonight on the crisis in ukraine
pro-russian separatists are now urging
hundreds of thousands of civilians to
leave the disputed regions and head to
russia claiming that a ukrainian attack
is imminent tonight after holding talks
with western leaders u.s president joe
biden responded with this
the device defies basic logic
to believe the ukrainians would choose
this moment with well over a hundred and
fifty thousand troops arrayed on its
borders to escalate a year-long conflict
the kremlin insists without evidence
that a genocide is now underway against
russian-speaking regions of ukraine
jackson proskow reports on fears that
pretext could be used by russia to
launch a full-scale invasion
sirens rang out over eastern ukraine
as the leaders of local pro-russian
governments told women and children to
flee and men to take up arms
i have to leave my home my apartment
because of all of this said this
russian-speaking resident
seven hundred thousand civilians are
reportedly headed to the border as the
self-proclaimed leader of the
separatists released a pre-recorded
video
a mass centralized evacuation of the
population to the russian federation has
been organized he claimed
evidence is growing that it may all be
part of a kremlin plan to manufacture a
pretext for invasion
a vehicle exploded in donetsk near a
pro-russian government building what the
u.s state department called a false flag
and ukrainian intelligence warned russia
was prepared to carry out terrorist
bombings that would then be blamed on
ukraine they will absolutely manufacture
an operation in order to create the
narrative that they want
to gain the political outcomes that
they're looking for the prospects for
avoiding war seem increasingly dim in
washington u.s president joe biden
reiterated the dire consequences russia
would face after a call with prime
minister trudeau and other nato allies
russia has a choice between war and all
the suffering it will bring or diplomacy
that will make a future safer for
everyone adding to the tension russia
has massive nuclear drills planned for
the weekend that vladimir putin is set
to personally oversee
the assessment has shifted from
uncertainty to near certainty that
russia will launch some kind of action
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that with avenues for putin to
back down increasingly limited and time
for diplomacy running out
that american certainty about a russian
invasion seems to be backed up by events
unfolding on the ground tonight russian
media reports that a major gas pipeline
in eastern ukraine has suffered some
sort of explosion and at the same time
jeff the u.s is all but certain that
russia is to blame for a series of cyber
attacks this week that took down
ukrainian banks and government websites
jackson proskow in washington tonight
thanks jackson
and with that threat of an invasion on
the rise poland is now preparing for a
sudden rush of ukrainians to the border
tens of thousands of people could be
displaced in the event of a russian
attack our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing is in poland tonight and has
more on the planned humanitarian
response
tucked away in an industrial park a
symbol recognized around the world
in the city of lublin in eastern poland
you'll find the red cross's largest base
in the country about two hours from the
border with ukraine
it's the polish government leading plans
to care for ukrainians should they need
to flee west
christian
i want to stress that we are ready to
help those who will be forced to leave
ukraine
the red cross anticipates there could be
as many as 50 000 people crossing into
poland per day should russia invade
the compounding effect could create a
humanitarian crisis on a tremendous
scale
while there's still lots of work to be
done the agency has some items in
holding from 2021 when there was a
crisis on the polish belarussian border
many refugees mostly from the middle
east were misled by officials in belarus
into thinking poland was an open entry
point into europe there are backpacks
and blankets and and cots and and some
of these items will actually be
repurposed for any ukrainians who happen
to cross the border
at the first stage there will be
refugees camps organized near the border
refugees will receive a medical and
social aid however those people must be
transported as fast as possible deeply
into poland territory to midland and to
the west because those people will not
be able to live for one week in
gymnasium
relocating those seeking refuge could
help poland more easily absorb the large
numbers of people
a similar strategy was used in 2014 when
fighting first broke out in the east of
ukraine between pro-russian separatists
and ukrainians polish government
officials say they're being guided by
the country's crisis management plans
and those will evolve based on the
situation on the ground
bottom line ukrainians will be welcomed
jeff
crystal comancing reporting in poland
tonight thanks
at least 11 people are now missing after
a ferry off the coast of greece burst
into flames the ship was about three
hours into its journey to italy more
than 200 people have been rescued
including a couple of truck drivers who
had to be airlifted off of the ferry the
cause of that fire is now under
investigation
canada's mounting metal count still
ahead more olympic glory for canadians
in beijing
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
the race is on for the last remaining
medals in beijing with the winter games
wrapping up on sunday and overnight two
canadian freestyle skiers landed on the
half pipe podium at the same time
defending champion bc's cassie sharp won
the silver medal while ontario's rachel
karker bagged the bronze making her
olympic debut one to remember it's
cassie sharp's second straight olympic
medal after winning gold in pyeongchang
in 2018 and she did it just one year
after undergoing major knee surgery
and team canada is also back on the
podium in men's curling newfoundland and
labrador skip brad gushu steered his
canadian rink to the bronze medal
defeating defending olympic champions
the united states eight to five
and it was redemption for a determined
laurent dubrey the quebec native skated
to a surprise silver medal in the men's
1000 meters the 29 year old only just
missed out on a medal in his signature
500 meter event and says that going the
extra distance made it extra special
next after weeks of protests how do
canadians really feel about covid19
vaccine mandates
[Music]
welcome back many of those protesters in
ottawa had set out to sway public
opinion on the issue of covid19 vaccine
mandates and restrictions but after
three weeks of honking horns and
blocking streets have they achieved
their goal eric sorenson has a deeper
look at the demonstration and what it
reveals about canadian society
[Music]
the protesters did have successes
turning small numbers into a big voice
and forcing governments to respond
there was sympathy for what many
genuinely endured i'm out here because
i've been hurt so much by this
by these mandates that i can't take it
anymore but in one crucial way they fell
short failing to spark a groundswell to
turn around majority opinion for many
the tactics were off-putting
the messaging at times extreme
and demands for immediate policy changes
seemed unrealistic the mandates are
still here so i'm not going most
canadians are fed up with restrictions i
genuinely understand the frustration but
saw them as a necessary evil everyone in
this country has to make sacrifices to
keep ourselves safe to keep everyone
else safe
we're canadian we're not just a country
of individuals
one guy on his ottawa balcony was turned
into a mock heritage minute profanely
telling convoy protesters to just go
home walk around
the vast majority of canadians accepted
the science that underpin vaccination
campaigns and other measures british
columbia still has restrictions that the
premier says have made a difference we
have been driven from the beginning on
the best available science to protect
people the policies were designed to
save lives and keep hospitals from being
overwhelmed vaccinations certainly have
made a difference in hospitalizations
this infectious disease expert does say
in hindsight mandates were coercive and
says lockdowns and how people were
affected should be examined for next
time there has been a significant
erosion of trust that's happened while
protesters have called for freedom
others say vaccines restored the freedom
to go out and feel safer doing so that
freedom of choice on vaccines ignores
the risks there's no such thing as total
freedom even people who choose to get
unvacciated we society pays for their
hospital bills we generally live in a
society where we have to make
concessions for the greater good
the protests have revealed deep rifts in
the country and even the police
crackdown is triggering a necessary
debate but the larger story of the
pandemic is two years of collective
perseverance by canadians that is
gradually seeing health restrictions
finally lifted which is what everyone
wants
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm jeff semple we leave you
tonight with one final look at the
situation in ottawa this overlooking
parliament hill we'll continue to follow
this developing story throughout tonight
and this weekend hope to see you back
here again tomorrow thanks for watching
have a great night